thank you to brilliant for sponsoring
this video
this is a video about what i think might
be the scariest climate science paper
i've ever read imagine a bucket that has
a hole in the bottom and is fed by a tap
if the flow of water out of the hole
matches the flow in from the tap the
level of water in the bucket stays
constant if however there is an
imbalance the level will not stay
constant if the hole gets clogged and
the flow through it decreases but the
inflow stays the same then the level of
water in the bucket will rise over time
imagine however that in the walls of
this bucket are some electrical wires
and these wires are connected to other
taps
if the level of the water reaches these
wires there's a chance they could short
circuit and turn on those extra taps the
level of the water would then increase
much faster and the water would be
electrified the bucket reached a tipping
point
one behavior a small imbalance in the
water coming in and the water leaving
causing the water level to rise
led to a new behavior a massive
imbalance of water entering the bucket
the earth's atmosphere is also currently
experiencing a minor imbalance recently
a species of mostly harmless mostly
hairless apes have started burning
carbon deposits they found in the ground
the extra carbon this burning has put
into the atmosphere has prevented some
thermal energy from leaving the planet
and that has increased the average
temperature of the atmosphere
historically scientists have said that
there's a pretty straightforward
relationship between the amount of
carbon in the earth's atmosphere and its
average temperature the more carbon in
the atmosphere the more warming takes
place in a logarithmic fashion but that
idea was complicated in 2005 with the
paper the thinning of arctic sea ice
1988-2003
have we passed a tipping point by
lindsay and zhang this was as far as i
can tell the first use of the phrase
tipping point in climate literature and
was soon developed by a legendary
scientist james hansen and particularly
in a 2008 paper by tim lenton at al
incidentally how we use the phrase
tipping point in climate science has
quite an interesting history i'll leave
a link to a paper below if you'd like to
learn more suffice to say i'm
simplifying things for this video lenten
ettel describes tipping elements parts
of the earth system which could with
just a nudge be changed from one state
to another and would have a large effect
on global climate if they did so the
point at which each tipping element
changes from one state to another is the
tipping point and each point is specific
to each element each tipping element
then is like an exposed wire in the
bucket and the tipping point is how high
each wire sits above the water line the
2008 paper highlighted nine tipping
elements which could impact world
climate perhaps the best known of these
is north atlantic deep water formation
which drives the thermo haline
circulation the big overturning
circulation of water in the atlantic
ocean if sufficient melt water entered
the north atlantic from greenland this
deep water formation could be disrupted
and the overturning circulation switched
off if this were to happen the northern
hemisphere could cool by several degrees
celsius and there could be a return of
ice age conditions to europe this effect
was dramatized in the film the day after
tomorrow now in our analogy this is like
a wire short circuiting not adding an
extra tap to the bucket but drilling an
extra hole in the bucket which is
incidentally what i wished had happened
to my head whilst i was watching the day
after tomorrow however the lentinet l
paper cites the ipcc assessment that
this was quote very unlikely to happen
before the year 2100 at least in a rapid
manner it was believed that climatic
tipping points could be reached this
century particularly in arctic sea ice
melting and melting of the greenland ice
sheet but that this was not likely
however to quote the paper given the
large uncertainty that remains about
tipping elements there is an urgent need
to improve our understanding of the
underlying physical mechanisms
determining their behavior so that
policymakers are able
to avoid the unmanageable and manage the
unavoidable in other words we knew they
were wise in the bucket but they were
quite high above the rising water line
we didn't know exactly where but we had
no reason to believe we would hit them
very soon however that was in 2008. this
month a new paper came out which counted
amongst its authors tim lenten now at
the university of exeter where i did my
phd it had the incredibly sobering title
exceeding 1.5 degrees c global warming
could trigger multiple climate tipping
points the authors reviewed over 200
peer-reviewed papers published since
2008 to assess our state of knowledge of
tipping points in the climate system
through paleoclimate data through modern
observations and through the output of
computer models the result they
increased the number of potential
tipping elements in the climate system
from 9 to 16. but that wasn't the
shocking part
the shocking part was that they
concluded we have already warmed the
planet to the point
where five of those tipping elements
could be triggered
now
the wires may already be in the water
just
waiting to short circuit collapse of the
greenland and west antarctic ice sheets
widespread abrupt permafrost thaw
collapse of convection in the labrador
sea and massive die-off of tropical
coral reefs are already possible at one
degree of warming that we have already
caused since pre-industrial times and to
be crystal clear we don't think any of
these tipping points have been reached
yet
but if they are reached there may be no
going back the changes may be
self-sustaining
to quote lenten that means even if
temperature stops rising once the ice
sheet ocean or rainforest has passed a
tipping point it will carry on changing
to a new state how long the transition
takes varies from decades to thousands
of years depending on the system for
example ecosystems and atmospheric
circulation patterns can change quickly
whilst ice sheet collapses slower but
leads to unavoidable sea level rise of
several meters ice sheet collapse would
eventually inundate coastal areas
permafrost thor would amplify our
man-made warming a collapse of the
circulation in the labrador sea would
bring the ice age back to europe and a
die-off of tropical corals would destroy
a key pillar of the marine ecosystem and
likely result in hundreds of millions of
people losing their primary source of
food
these are events that you could
justifiably call apocalyptic further if
the planet warms by one and a half
degrees celsius then five more tipping
points become possible and four that
were possible at one degree of warming
become
likely and as i'm sure i don't need to
remind you we are not on track to limit
warming to just one and a half degrees
as i've covered in a previous video
under current government policies we're
looking at maybe 3.2 degrees of warming
by the year 2100 if all the pledges made
at cop 26 are perfectly converted into
action
maybe 1.8 degrees of warming currently
we are walking towards a cliff edge that
is crumbling into the sea and the ground
could fall away from us at any moment
yet we still plan to keep walking right
up to the edge this is the point in a
normal video where i would try and
writing it to pull things out of the bag
and weave these conclusions together
into something that's kind of satisfying
and you leave the video feeling all
right but um
yeah
i can't do that today i've read a lot of
papers in climate science and i've read
about a lot of bad news in climate
science but for some reason this paper
chilled my blood
i think it's because i still think of
the climate as being something that we
are in control of it's something that we
are forcing with our emissions of
greenhouse gases and so something that
we could stop forcing if we wanted to we
could stop warming the planet
but
this paper says that that isn't always
the case our hands are on the wheel up
to a point
beyond which we are powerless to stop
what happens next if the planet sets
itself down a path that makes it
uninhabitable for humans whether that's
in millennia or in decades
there's nothing we can do about it and i
don't know about you but i find that
terrifying so if this paper says
anything anything at all it's that every
tenth of a degree
counts every tenth of a degree that we
can avoid warming the planet is
important every step we can avoid taking
towards that crumbling cliff edge is
worth fighting for at the moment we
still have our hands on the wheel we
still have control of our destiny we
haven't crossed any of these tipping
points yet but the fact is we are simply
not doing enough to be confident of
avoiding an uninhabitable earth
so
while we still have the power to do so
let's please
do something about it
i don't think a smooth segue into a
sponsor would be appropriate for this
video so i would really appreciate if
you could just stick around for a minute
to hear a bit about brilliant who made
this video possible brilliant have been
a long time supporter of this channel
and that's because they are the perfect
fit for people that like watching my
videos they are all about improving your
understanding of maths science and
computer science through gorgeously
illustrated interactive courses
available on the website and in an app
brilliant offers courses across a huge
range of subjects from fundamental to
graduate level for example if you found
this video interesting then perhaps
you'll enjoy their course on knowledge
and uncertainty or maybe their
introductory course on science
essentials each course is designed to
introduce you to new concepts and then
immediately apply them helping you learn
by doing rather than just memorizing
paragraphs of a textbook it's designed
to be an ideal companion to traditional
classroom learning but it's also a great
fit for people without much time who
want to continue their learning journey
in science i've never been anything less
than impressed by brilliant and they are
constantly improving they're always
adding new courses and improving old
ones so it only gets easier and easier
to recommend them brilliant are well
brilliant and if you haven't checked
them out yet you really really should to
get started for free go to brilliant.org
simon clark and the first 200 people to
do so will get 20 off their annual
subscription i can highly recommend it
and thank you so much to brilliant for
sponsoring this video
thank you very much for watching this
video all the way to the end i
appreciate this isn't easy watching but
this is a topic that i think we all need
to understand if you'd like to learn
more about the climate crisis here's my
video on recommended reads about climate
and here's a video about more positive
actions that we can actually take to
stop the crisis so as well as checking
out brilliant down here and subscribing
to the channel please do go and watch
those
thank you again for watching and i'll
see you in the next one